so the impeachment trial is over and no
witnesses were called this is the second
time there's been an impeachment in the
last year
with no witnesses being called but
there's several reasons why the house
managers might not have wanted to call
witnesses first of all congress says
they want to get back to governing
i think they should be able to do two
things at once but more to the point
they were worried about what the
witnesses would have said most of the
witnesses with
extremely relevant information would
have been close to the trump camp and
who knows what they would have said but
this is the classic trial lawyers
dilemma you never know what a witness is
going to say
on the stand but you could have
ameliorated that by taking depositions
of those witnesses to know ahead of time
what their testimony would be and while
this was unfortunate
the evidence was overwhelming i would
have liked to have seen more of a
factual record with witnesses but
look the evidence was there but what do
i know i'm just a lawyer and speaking of
which
subscribe or i'll see you in court